from the studio behind the Animated
Classics that defined a generation and
the bloated gritty live-action reboot
that defined this generation comes
another Disney cash-grab that will ruin
everything you loved about another
childhood classic male efficient male
thickened male a Vikings screw it
Sleeping Beauty - giant cheekbones
star in the modern retelling of Sleeping
Beauty this time from the villains
perspective where the character you
loved for being pure evil and turning
into an awesome dragon is no longer evil
doesn't even turn into a dragon why is
he the dragon you had one job Disney
instead watches the sorceress whose name
literally means evil mildly Punk's
people feel sorry
you stole who's left at my house and now
I've lost you for him and his only mean
because she was roofied and mutilated by
her childhood love uh have fun
explaining that to your kids watch
everything scary and fun about
Maleficent get neutered by the same
thing that neutered Darth Vader
backstory
where you'll learn the answers to
questions you never had like what if
Maleficent grew up in a low-rent avatar
ripoff what if the original was full of
generic CGI battle scenes was Maleficent
pet crow actually a human slave where
did her stick come from and did
Maleficent spend most of her time
creepily watching Sleeping Beauty grow
up from a few feet away yes she did
apparently I hate you but it's not just
the angelina jolie show instead spend
time with one-dimensional caricatures
like the mean king the handsome prince
the cute princess and the three fairies
you loved from the original who are now
three hideous idiots who stupidity
borders on child abuse look the little
beast is about to fall off the cliff way
to fairies Disney so experience a more
modern take on Sleeping Beauty where we
learn the most important lesson of all
if your movie comes out after frozen an
act of true love true love's kiss true
love only exists between two girls all
yeah starring you know nothing Jon Crow
Huey Dewey and Louie
groots Harry Styles areola Ron King and
have Jennifer Aniston See's Angelina
Jolie Sleeping Beauty the bad one we're
gonna be honest this wasn't our best
trailer but this wasn't Disney's best
movie either
next week's will be way better trust us
be sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers roses are red violets are blue
I suck at poems babes chicken nugget
booty salad I don't want your damn
lemons Star Wars The Force awakens
whosoever holds this
hammer if he be worthy shall possess the
power of Thor there are no strings on me